what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to start up the series eight
episode run season one of Reacher how do we
come here well we got some requests I've been
interested in this show because it's cultivated
quite a fan base and that surprised the heck out
of me so I was like you know what this has been on
my Q you might as well convert it to the channel
it follows our criteria of what we decide to
react to on the main page and our patreon as
well so ladies and gentlemen if you go ahead
smash that like button like this guy's biceps
who's ever playing Jack retronome who this guy
is I I don't think I've even seen the trailer for
this I just know he's tall and of an appropriate
build as compared to Tom Cruise it actually fits
the description of the book this is what I've
heard that's all I've heard and also be sure
to subscribe click the notification Bell because
we do want to make it through the rest of these
episodes as well full-length Reaction watch along
is where you sync up with your own copy of Reacher
available for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page but because this is the first episode
the first full-length Reaction watch
along is available for the public so
you'll find a link in the description box and
pin comment but also at our patreon we cover
a bunch of stuff over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch how
long is included let's see what all the hype's
about let's see if it lives up to oh the talk
foreign
good shot
someone's mad die
now who's gonna know that dude got shot
wasn't it just pouring rain a second okay it
still is okay depending on what part of the
country you're in you know you can walk
10 feet and it'll be not raining anymore
or maybe it's symbolism that it's a brighter
day now that Jack Reacher has arrived sorry
40 how am I supposed to God
damn money I'm on his side
the hell you won't [__] he
wants to save the cat moment
listen man I'm just having a bad day
that was cool all I had to do is look at
it until he would change his expression
one bit that was cool black and peach pie
best you're gonna find in Georgia but they
all say that kind of looks like a super buff
Sam Worthington yeah sure let's get it done
[Music]
oh my that's Jack Reacher's diet is always bye
reach your water they get caught Andy left a 40
tip hands behind her head hands behind her head
interlock your fingers Flex
those biceps you're under arrest
for murder oh snap he was just on a bus if
you step over here I can process you I'm not
asking sir I'm telling but don't worry I won't
kick your ass unless you make me I like her all
right what is your name Sasquatch don't talk
Jack Reacher zip ties cuffs didn't fit them
that's why you don't skip four arms 212.
this looks like some kind of foreign deal
World War II metal French I'm
Chief detective Oscar Finley I
was informed you were read you're right
so you know you don't have to answer
confirmed victim was male 30s big guy
no idea yet problem getting prints off
the body's swollen fingertips I love how you
can see he's processing all this information
maybe your court appointed
attorney will get you to open up
I don't need a lawyer so far run on his Prince
has been clean but something could still turn up
but there's no Facebook Snapchat Instagram him
he's not an influencer he's a teacher people
How to shed those pounds retired army what if
I'm thinking I'm sitting across from a man who
doesn't mind killing and who has the knowledge
and training to murder someone and cover it up
you'd be right where'd you get that conclusion
three men dropped this body shooter was someone
who knows Firearms well he also knew enough to
pick up his brass this wasn't a first timer this
was someone who knew how to conduct a quiet
effective kill nice nice you're also looking
for a psycho who'd beat up a body postmortem
someone completely unhinged something wrong no
your psycho isn't suddenly going to be rational
enough to know he has to hide the body in your
meticulous shooter isn't going to do a sloppy job
with roadside cardboard well the third guy is so
worried about getting out of there he grabs some
nearby debris and just lays it across the corpse
I got off the bus from Tampa and
walked to town I asked the driver
to do me a favor why on account of blind
blink Legend has it he died in margrave
long time ago I figured I'd learn a
bit about him I like music [Laughter]
medical examiner puts the victim's time of death
at around midnight last night this morning it's
last night until 11 59 and 59 seconds and
then it becomes this morning [Laughter]
laughs running down a phone number found in the
dead guy's shoe means I'm gonna be here for a
while foreign companies are slow responding to
warrants like it they're kind of figuring out
the case together yeah unlikely Duo father and
I will unpack you too go and meet the base kids
this is home now hopefully for a while and go
make friends it's gonna be like Army Shazam
Soldier that's the way to the beach yeah that's
five bucks for the looks about your jacket yeah
I'm big for my age just like you're ugly
for your age oh you could be ugly anytime
let's get some Stephen King bullies going
you don't have to do this
it's my fight that's cool
we're taking a ride got hit on the
phone number yeah the phone company
stepped it up you invited me over
to chat but never asked what crime
I just wanted to get you over here so we
could talk [Laughter] male shot to death
he was found with your number written
on a paper scrap in his shoe I did it
however it doesn't believe
him he did what was his name
I don't know you killed a man
you don't know yeah that's right
self-defense in the back of the head terrible
story I'm not about to rehash all the details
you are my second annoying interrogation today
a double barrel shotgun blast right to the face
yes and then burnt the body smart yes I did smart
I love this detective not sure
if I've seen this actor before
but yeah this lead detective is great [Music]
come with me not until you let these
zip ties come off get the boss cutter
it's okay I got it of course you do
that's good don't want to get ridden up for
littering in the police station you guys recycle
awesome
I was just cleared one guy lied about
killing another guy that doesn't clear
you good town of murdering even when
he confessed nothing happens to you
bars on bars this guy might still have information
to share I don't Stevenson does he and Hubble were
looking at each other they looked at each other
they held eye contact for a full two Mississippi
you're always so confident in your
theories as confident as I am that
you went to Harvard you recently
divorced and you quit smoking in
the last six months nice you're stubborn you
have a chip on your shoulder you don't care
if your co-workers like you a guy like
that doesn't go to BU he goes to Harvard
yes you're also about 40 which means
you did your 20 at Boston PD to get
your pension so you can afford a proper
Southern soup but you still look like
black Sherlock [Laughter] holmese as for the
smoking when I broke down the three murderers
back there you started to think you had the
wrong guy the water in your class moved a bit
we're not on any major fall lines a major
Lane was bouncing onto the table you know you
know you need him he'll solve the case oh sure
it's Holmes Versus Holmes Stevenson my office
try not to look so guilty right now
the show is pretty cool all I know
is that at midnight he was nowhere near that
Highway a couple in the trunks no he cheat on
his wife no he's a family don't answer
his questions he's not your boss right
do you have money problems I
don't know what to do [Laughter]
the only way you'll know why Hubble
confess is if he tells you yeah well
maybe a week in a lockup will motivate
him let me know what he says now Chief
Morrison wants you in custody till we know
for sure that all six foot four of you was
on that bus from Tampa six foot five we
keep extra large Cuffs in our lock box
es tall inventory is watching ring
they'll stealing first five minutes
he's in there it was nice talking to you
ship them this is really engaging yeah hasn't even
been any action scenes but it's a lot of deductive
action scenes but a Samoan fella come to here
last year met dealer and scrubs made up special
I would hate to take off my shirt next to that
guy yep drop them drawers bend over and spread
no the victim I'm suspected of murdering
was shot by a handgun that would measure
four inches by six that weapon's not
fitting inside me or any other human
being without sending them
to the hospital [Laughter]
so if you think you can perform the inspection
without getting seriously injured go for it
break those fingers with your butt cheeks
otherwise check the box on your clipboard
you can inspect him I don't care
yeah in fact please inspect it
let's get a room together yeah he can protect
him he'll be partners and I like the movie the
one time I saw it but this show makes me
go this must be a good book yeah all right
it does a good job of capturing the mystery of
who this guy is really well too what's going on
we're not with the guys awaiting
arraignment where were the lifers
what do you mean life first I mean
people sentenced for Life yep what wow
oh you have to survive you got a
first visitor there she is no no
give him shoes baby you heard me get
my shoes a good little [__] good girl
like glasses too get my glasses that's messed
up yeah that's mean the shoes I can abide but
yeah there's just one more thing
I want from you oh my [Laughter]
God go see you're in my house
Fatso and you didn't ask permission
so you and your friends can leave now where
they can carry your fat ass out in a bucket
nice I take the bucket now I'll count to three
[__] do you know what you're talking to one
two
that's brutal and efficient
you owe us a pair of glasses
those will supplement those lenses yep that's
cool I wanna I wanna Jack Reacher in my life
it's got the shades now the only thing keep
me alive in here in big trouble no [__]
I'm not a criminal currency manager yeah
whose currency are you managing my boss
is Promised if I disrupt their operation in
any way they'd they'd nailed me to a wall hey
cut my books off and make me eat them it's a
veil threat I gotta take all that time and effort
it's with this specific group here
I'm gonna hit the head that guy's head
sweet bathroom fight kill him with a bar soap I
love bathroom fights break someone's
head on a toilet on a sink anything
oh what is going on we need protection if you boys
knew what's about to happen to you you'd leave now
so I'll give you to the count of three one
wow oh my God
yes oh wow that was violent kill or
be killed you don't shank Jack Reacher
wait
my report says you were placed upstairs why are
you and Jen popular that's where the guy put us
it's much calmer here
this guy just wants to chill I
think he just wanted a vacation
divorce and quitting cigarettes it's me um I'm
just uh I'm just dealing with the tough case of
missing you got Reacher's military record from DC
West Point graduate Silver Star defense Superior
service medal Legion of Merit soldiers
medal Army Commendation Medal Bronze Star
and a Purple Heart for wounds sustained
in the bombing of a Marine's barracks in
Kandahar woof got the license plate too Jack
Reacher's the murderer return to active duty
32 hours later despite having shrapnel remains
of a jaw bone removed from his abdomen whoa
what is this man what in God's name is a guy like
that doing in margrave it's
a guy like that doing in jail
Jack Reacher solving the case for you
Jack Reacher did the murder because
nobody's good enough to outsmart him
now so he just has to outsmart himself
[Laughter]
give in to Temptation I would have just thrown
them out yeah having them at
all is kind of a guarantee
I'm more curious why whoever you work for
wants me dead and gone from last night's baby
you set us up in genpop he played off like
it was some kind of innocent mistake but it
was intentional guys in the shower I
need me as a person to take out damn
something bad's going down in my grave and
I don't need to be a part of it famous last
words shitty sandwich did look good though my
wife should be here soon I don't give a [__]
any idea your car could use lip
uh taking a shine to him he's been in prison
a long time thank you some love imagine love
reachers like Greyhound confirm that's their Tampa
station two nights ago that way you could've been
a more grave in time to kill anyone so you cleared
me but how does a guy who confessed walk away
but he knows that Hubble's line so Hubble's
probably dead huh Roscoe's actually my first name
cool so what's your last name chicken and Wok
that's a very unique name I'm on the next bus
out of here I feel bad about the margrave Welcome
Wagon running over understandable I was going to
apologize within a really dinner but if you're
not sticking around okay oh do it but I'm gonna
need some new clothes first um we got a moralsman
chop in town a proper shower too what about money
pensions wired to a Western Union each month
don't you miss your family they're all dead
except for my brother Joe he's a good guy
where's he an upcoming episode Joe's the
killer damn it I'm here because of blind Blake
read some article about Blake said he played his
last show in margrave and that's where he died so
you just go wherever you want whenever you want
everyone's always jealous so I'll check out the
town for a while see you in a bit sounds good
and don't go getting yourself
rested for murder again
that truck everything's suspicious that truck
at Coca-Cola sign that pickup
it's not just a sponsor [Music]
the truck the truck's back I'm trusted but
a Blues fan might be able to tell me a bit
about blind Blake's time in margrave most
surprise you know blind Blake Mr Richard
Foundation takes care of Margaret that statue
out there his grandsons I met he gave Klein a
sweetheart pickup truck that does Klein a Junior
and his Bug House cousin Dawson I call him
trouble do you want to dance to Tom burrito with
me hell I'll dance I'm talking to your beauty
talking the guy in price of your boots better hair
cutting expensive truck he lets you sit shotgun in
you want me to lead her I'm not much of
a dancer more of an academic and a reader
you found his mansion reading something
interesting just this morning about some
charges brought against a major Jack Reacher in
a small village outside of Baghdad a very serious
nature but charges that somehow disappeared
like grains of sand and unforgiving desert
ah you are a reader what's your back Mr Richard
you threw him off his game yeah it's like
I'll be sticking around another body was
found the brush 40 yards from the first
one same caliber bullet can't say I'm not
disappointed I was looking forward to
spending time with you before leaving
huh well I don't know if we're going anywhere just
yet did Hubble talk when you two were locked up
no you're not going anywhere my alibi clear
maybe I need to bring in a forensic expert to
confirm it was you and maybe you need to cool
your heels back in Warburton and while we get
that done open next two or three weeks just say
you need his help this second guy he was shot
in the back of the head while running away but
his legs kept humming for a few more feet before
his brain told him hey buddy you're dead Gamo
killer just left him there no ID on him Killers
an investigation Details Matter he's my first
murder so please tell me you know who did this
his fingertips were compromised by dermatitis
reaction so swollen prints wouldn't come out clean
until I drink some of the fluid we're waiting for
the results what whoa um is he new on the force or
first victim was allergic to latex his Dental
Works off because he had his teeth fixed wherever
he was living at the time broke his right
arm when he was eight had it set in Berlin
had his tonsils taken out of
10 in Soul travel the corpse
oh [Music]
he knows this man seems like it by his expression
we were wrestling I pinned them against the stove
I didn't know my mother just turned it off is that
Joe is that Joe that's how
my brother got this score
what so Joe is the killer so it's just a
coincidence you and he are passing through the
exact same photo town at the exact same moment in
time I don't know when's the last time you saw Joe
a minute ago in the morgue I'm being straight
with you well no wonder Sharon left you oh
okay my wife's name no enough that aged well
I know you're not the kind of guy to beat up
on somebody half your size without good reason
he's giving me a reason yeah well I know people
and you've got condos
Joe did not look much better looking I did
not keep that reach or hairline just thinking
maybe my brother told me about blind Blake for
a reason thinking I'm supposed to do something
about it I guess I'll find everybody
responsible for you yeah Kill Them All
ah title card damn that's a great oh that's
a great first episode yeah man it's riveting
it's crazy when I believed the most I was the
one I believed the most was that Joe's bad guy
predictable for an unpredictable show sure sure
who could give me this run for my money is my own
brother yeah yeah that was good that was really
good yeah I didn't catch any of the cast name
I will only know them by their archetypes and
uh certain personality traits and physical
descriptions sure and I only know Harvey Guillen
it's Harvey Guillen he was the coroner at the
end he's on what we do in the shadows and was
in Puss in Boots too that's who you know yeah
not you Guillermo well um yeah I mean oh wait
we've got seven more episodes to get through
so keep this relatively short yeah uh I was
really impressed with this I thought it had a
great Rhythm and a good energy about it I've
I often find myself the characters like Jack
Reacher going what is the threat here what
is a way to make someone like Jack Reacher
feel like he's an actual danger because it
just seems like he's like he's awesome like
he's awesome like he's so awesome and like I
don't I don't know if any guy like him truly
exists but he's sorry he's so incredibly Wally
he's perfect and you know like a physical threat
and an intellectual threat to mental game threat
you can't seem to get a a one-up on this guy ever
and so to have this mystery come come to his
doorstep here with his dead brother and to
be confronted with it where you can feel the
emotional toll I think that's what makes it
fascinating when you're with what they pose
as like the things that could hinder him is
being stunted a little bit by uh the triggers
of certain pains within which I find really
interesting I don't know if that's like the full
direction of where the show's gonna go I imagine
that there will be some actual physical threats or
he's going to whoop ass left and right for seven
more episodes uh but I like that situation where
the guy brought up the the clothes the buried case
in Baghdad and you could see that there was there
was a disturbance in the force in that moment and
then of course with his brother as well you
you can you can feel that pain and that kind
of pain that can like motivate him or it could or
maybe throw him off of his game and so I really I
really liked a lot I never plays him I don't know
his name and I'll I'll try to learn it by the end
of the series but I thought he was great you know
uh like I don't I wasn't interested in the show
when it first came out I only became interesting
because people kept asking about it and and I I
like the first Jack Reacher movie and I never
was in love with it I really hated the second
one that was awful not good that was an awful
film not a good movie um and I'll say you know
for what I while I like Tom Cruise a lot in
them in that first movie there's still like
a variation of Tom Cruise 100 and watching this
you can really see kind of how it was molded to
being Tom Cruise yeah yeah well a much bigger
teeth grinning sure Jack Reacher is not really
that here and I've heard the comparisons of why
book readers were upset with Tom Cruise's casting
like a lot of it came down first to the
physicality of him but I really love that they
did here was the reintroduction I I don't know
who this actor is maybe I've seen him in something
before and I'm just not recalling at this moment
uh I thought he brought a lot of weight to his
performance and you know both physically and
mysteriously because when he's first introduced
I do like the imposing figure the build that he
is when he first walks on the screen it's awesome
but then they don't lead with action and that
was the probably the first thing I noticed was
how they're not trying to sell you on who he
is by by level of action at all even though the
first thing you that strikes you is this guy's
massive it's like he's a massive dude and it's
cool to get a dude who is like that massive but
is superiorly intellectual totally and you don't
really get the hybrid of that I can't think
of too many characters like nothing I'm sure
exists uh I'm sure I've seen something that I
love with that kind of character but you don't
you don't really get that on screen it's usually
one or the other and to get a character like that
here where everything that well why whatever my
vague recollection is that I've heard of people
who complained about the Jack Reacher movie
who were fans of the book I see that that's
really been brought over here and as someone who
hasn't read the book I felt like that works much
better like I found this really engaging from
beginning to end yeah as compared to what I
remember in my experience of the first movie
which was like cool in the wash and whatever
um this was uh I could see I could see how people
like I would I would continue watching the show if
I just wanted to if I just stumbled on the pilot
yeah absolutely and I think yeah it strikes a
really nice balance both with the character and
just in the with the tone in general it's been a
little while I feel like since I've had something
like this in my viewing diet where yeah you have
the obvious action elements the obvious you know
badass stuff but it does feel like much more than
the Tom Cruise movie like you are in the world
of a novel of a crime novel and of that sort
of lyricality that space that air that kind of
permeates everything and yeah like setting the
stage here like there are a lot of tropes you know
like ah Drifter rolls into town just at the time
you know a murder happens and he's always cool and
collected but yeah I thought they played nicely on
his character where yeah you meet everybody else
because they're agitated by how calm he is and
then by the end of the episode you do get a couple
moments that rile him up one in a subtle way and
then one in a very overt emotional kind of way
and I can only imagine we'll see more flashbacks
of him and Joe growing up and things like that
but yeah just the way they displaced everything
the way that they introduced all the characters uh
Finley and Roscoe especially I thought were really
you know nice additions and and the things that
they are not editions but just like you know nice
um you know important yeah like main
supporting presences that are going
to help flesh this journey out that
much further and yeah having him have
this you know like timid Banker guy along with him
and expecting him to be the body of it like there
were just like a lot of nice twists and turns
that don't feel too much like uh like they're you
know look how clever we are you know like it does
just genuinely draw you in with a good amount of
it feels I don't know something about the way
that they've orchestrated it here feels lived
in because he does have all that mystique and
yes he is like a lot more smart and articulate
and well-read than you would expect but he
feels like a real guy in his portrayal of that
and even his silence in the first parts of the
episode where you're just watching him kind of
process everything and you're watching him speak
with his eyes and his thought process as really
nicely tailored I feel like across this and the
tone the mood the way they capture the town the
way they use the music and the thread of his you
know interest in blues and the reason he came to
uh margrave in the first place this is all yeah
just like really colorful and interesting that's
fun yeah it's a fun show sure it's like genuinely
fun yeah and this is one of those shows that I I
could see being a true worldwide appeal and like
what I mean by that is I I can imagine going to
like my in-laws house I would see like the older
folk watching this show yeah but I get all these
young karate he's gonna join too like yeah
it is it is one of those shows or you you can
definitely see like the people in the Midwest
and stuff just watching the show everyone yeah
yeah yeah anybody can get into it it seems like
yeah because yeah it's not particularly it's not
it's not commenting on that so on on like the
town it doesn't seem like it's looking down on
the people of the town or anything like that
you know and yeah it's like the kind of hero
yeah anybody could get behind and it is a fun
mystery to try to solve as well uh-huh they
they have a good mystery of float and yeah
like the performances Finley cop Maine cop
yeah Finley's good really really good and he the
psychological profile on him was a great way to
get some Exposition on the character that's I
think that's like smart Exposition because it
tells you who that character is and it also tells
you about Jack Reacher at the same time foreign
like this was cool because yeah there is action
and the action is cool it is satisfying when it
happens but I think they did wisely to both draw
that out and and create tensions to the when the
action pops off it really hits but there's a lot
that does feel like just as intense but it's just
people sizing each other up and kind of examining
little Clues and you know sparring back and forth
mentally and I think that's another thing that's
impressive when you can really make that vital I
mean the show's cool and got swag and like um
even though for YouTube we got to remove As
Much from the music swag the the music the music
fits it well like the music doesn't tell me how
to feel like you just kind of that's sort of
just the vibe in the aura it just feels like
you're there yeah yeah it's cool and I like the
small towns a lot like in real life I really
love going to small towns so having this show
set in a small town I think is really neat and
unpacking uh murder mysteries are more fun when
they're in a small town setting it's more personal
oh yeah one small town murder that's that's that
you know everybody appeal that I feel like right
now it's just where's the small town is it in
Scandinavia it is in the heartland of America
you're like that's your flavor but yeah it's it's
like classic but also it's got enough of the fresh
unique elements too and it's shot cool and it's
R-rated yeah yeah they throw down man like that's
that was a a bloody fight in a way that's not
in your face but also where you do feel the
impact and and yeah yeah it's nicely Jack Russell
remember was PG-13 right yeah I'm pretty sure it
is yeah but I believe it's PG-13 we're yeah this
is this is all right it's not like super hard R
yet there were a couple of moments that were like
wow that is really R-rated well yeah and I could
I could imagine if there there will probably
be future murders and I can certainly imagine
them getting into the autopsy the the coronary
side of it too you know and and that you know
grossness that comes with that yeah and there's
a lot of respect to about the way it's shot you
know I thought it was actually really smart to
not even show Joe's face just to keep it more
about the presence of Joe's dead body and keep it
on Jack Reacher's expression I thought this was
really cool and that was really really cool yeah
it was pleasant I really enjoyed it yeah a lot
from beginning to end it was very very enjoyable
and very engaging didn't let me go suck me in
and didn't let me go all right guys well what did
you think about Reacher is it just called Reacher
I think so all right hey they wanted to really
distinct divide I was 100 not that short guy uh
yeah okay this is called reach room what did you
guys think about Reacher did you enjoy it leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like you can catch us on patreon and hey
let's send this with a patreon Chris wamoth I feel
like Chris Wham off is the perfect person to shout
out for Reacher because what we know about Chris
is the guy is this Samaritan yes the right word
he is he is a Samaritan finding people helping out
when he doesn't have to often in small towns yep
yeah actually yeah because he's really accurate
we don't need a it's apparently [__] our way
through here this is actually really all true
yeah the only the only thing I'm not sure about
is if you're you know supremely buff you know but
I I feel like you probably take good care of your
body given what I know about your disposition so
you're probably at least fit he's been arrested
before for helping out dude that's the way to
get arrested all right here's a good reason to be
arrested just like could you could you stop making
the rest of us look bad we're gonna detain you now
yeah man yeah that's it you're at the Jack Reacher
of our patreon page we have found the character to
call you from now on oh yeah the Jack Reacher of
our patreon you're the peach pie of of our dessert
here at the at the super sexy reject Hub super
sexy p-jack tub and uh and hey I mean if you were
watching our backs I would never worry I would
never lose an ounce of sleep in my life because
I would feel so safe and secure just knowing
you're out there you know I hope you wander
through La sometime and get arrested for trying to
do too much good and then we can bail you out and
then finally feel good about ourselves and then
you can make that up to us by upping your pledge
because we don't have enough to bail you
out how much bail costs in Los Angeles
I don't know Jack reach around yeah what's
that that is a film I'm working on right now
that's what I've heard of it yeah
I I waiting for your script notes
gonna be a really rich and narrative
adult film all right [Music]